hey David you've interviewed a lot of
extremists on the David Pakman show
there's now a debate about platforming
and a battle of ideas where is the line
between platforming Dangerous Ideas and
simply having a battle of ideas
excellent question
I've been engaged in a bunch of Twitter
discussions about this recently
including with people like Kyle kolinsky
of secular talk and others here's what
it comes down to responsible platforming
okay my approach to this question of
there's someone with an outrageous
horrible idea do you interview them
potentially giving them an opportunity
to spread their propaganda and to
convince more people of what they what
they believe but or do you ignore them
completely with the idea that their
ideas will go away and the answer is
like most things it depends okay when we
consider having an extremist on I'm
evaluating two basic things number one
are their ideas prominent enough that
they are worth refuting okay that's
number one so for example I've never
interviewed anyone on the program who
believes that to my knowledge I've never
interviewed anyone on the program about
the belief that Paul McCartney died and
was replaced by another left-handed
bassist who looks a lot like him and
sounds a lot like him when he sings it's
not a prominent enough thing and it's
not of consequence to the point where I
think it's even worth refuting but let's
say it were worth refuting then I go to
characteristic number two in my
decision-making process which is am I
going to be well enough equipped to do
the refuting okay and I don't do as good
a job of this as I would like but when I
bring on an extremist without rageous
ideas
I don't simply take the position of tell
me about what you believe oh really
that's interesting oh all Jews should
should self-immolate oh that that's very
interesting yeah and why do you think
that oh and though what kind of fire
starter should they be using no that's
not what I would consider responsible
platforming right I need to be prepared
to really challenge a challenge head-on
the liabilities of the underlying
philosophy the implications history
whatever I don't always do as good of a
job as I want to do with this but at
least that's my goal okay so for me the
line between the dangerous platforming
of ideas and engaging in a battle of
ideas is less about the person and the
ideas in a vacuum but it's a calculation
as to whether the person and bad ideas
are prominent enough to be worth
refuting and am I going to be positioned
well enough to refute those ideas if the
answer to either of those questions is
no then I don't do it because I think I
do risk providing a sort of propaganda
platform that could of run completely
counter to what I think are the goals of
my program other people would handle it
differently there are plenty of people
out there many of you know who they are
who invite horrible extremists with vile
and disgusting ideas with the idea that
they just want to hear from them they
want to hear what the ideas are they're
not there to provide counter points
they're not there to provide opposition
or even to suggest that these are
disgusting ideas dangerous ideas violent
ideas that's not me okay that's not what
I do
plenty of shows for people who like that
other approach but I don't think it's
particularly responsible so hopefully
that kind of gives you a sense of my
approach